Stanley greenberg author of middle-class
Dreams he quote Frederick Lewis Allen as
saying that the election of 1896 perhaps
is the most important in the whole
history of the United States
oh come well as I as I tried to work my
way back from our current period and I
actually I started with it with a couple
simple ideas I've been I've been hearing
over and over again as I talked to
people when you ask them what's what
what's the Democratic Party what do you
associate with the Democratic Party they
say it's it's a party of the party of
the people it's for a little guy and
you're asked about the Republican Party
and they say it's a business-oriented
party I can I'll get that answer whether
I ask some young kid who's never who's
new who has no recollection of America's
political history or if I ask a senior
citizen that won't tell me the same
thing
Republican and Democrat they'll tell me
the same thing and so part of the
motivation his book was to try to
understand you know those those simple
ideas in people's heads and what I found
in the course of writing the book is I
kept coming back to 1896 as a as an
election that was came in depression in
which the really it was really the first
moderate election of which the which the
parties were shaped by the modern
industrial order and we had you know
we've gone through other elections
particularly you know since the Civil
War which we're living with the remnants
of that struggle and then reconstruction
and then you entered a competitive
period in which was unclear which party
would be ascendant but 1896 was really
the first election about how it is we
organized a modern industrial America
and how did we achieve prosperity how it
is that ordinary citizens prosper as the
country prospers and there were two
major worldviews put on the table in
that election from when William Jennings
Bryan a populist view of the world
regionally-based but you know inserted
that the purpose of government is to
protect the common person against the
power the against the great powerful
institutions of the country both private
and public and then on the other side
you had really the first articulation
from
Kinley the idea that if American
capitalism to survive you did I guess
you've won we could go back to Hamilton
and fund some of this but it was the
election was really was cast in these
terms with McKinley making the case that
a business led prosperity would bring
prosperity of the country as a whole and
he he went well beyond the the the way
these had been spoken about before he
was a strong protectionist protect
American industry build up American
industry and out of that process we
would be able to have prosperity for the
ordinary worker he and McKinley McKinley
came out of a working-class district in
Ohio or he had been running and trying
to persuade working working class people
Union members even a time supported
strikers persuade them that their future
lie with business so McKinley made the
case for a business led prosperity it it
produced a three decade-long great
Republican Ihram which I write about
where the idea of business led
prosperity was a central notion it was
interrupted only by the the splintering
of the of the Republican Party allowing
Wilson to come into office but it really
didn't change the three decade rule
through Coolidge up til up to Hoover on
which it was the idea of business led
prosperity was the the conventional
wisdom of the country it's forged in
depression three decades three decades
long the Democrats were seen out of that
election as even though populist and for
the common person they were also seen to
be anti progress anti change and we're
marginalized in the in the election what
happened then in in thirty two was the
again depression a three decade party
era afford but this time from the bottom
up the notion that if you could give the
common person some stability economic
stability and rising living standards
that the country as a whole would
prosper anyway three decades of a great
Democratic era interrupted only by
Eisenhower was a military hero but I
believe it all started in 1896 that was
the formative election in which a bottom
up party and a top down party who
dominated our political scene for now
for a good part of a century it's not
clear that party order now
any longer fits the emerging economy
that's one of the great challenges we
face but I but I think we we begin in
1896 have you always been interested in
history yeah I'd say that's true I mean
I was trained as a political scientist
and I've always been a bit politically
active as long as I can remember
beginning with the civil rights movement
and the I did my doctoral dissertation
on the politics of poor neighborhoods in
the United States but when I went to
write the book off of that which was
eventually called politics and poverty I
decided to deal with it historically
look at the the flow of immigration from
how Latino communities were formed and
in the southwest and the and how the
flow of immigration came from Mexico and
tried to understand the flow of
immigration from out of this out of the
deep south to create the the urban
communities of the Detroit and
Philadelphia so I'm always pushed trying
to push it my understanding back
historically as a way of making sense of
the president Senator Chris Dodd was
bragging on the radio this morning that
you started with his campaign in 1980 is
that accurate
that's absolutely true absolutely true
of it I did I did I mean I did polling
as an academic and I as a as a hobby I
would sometimes help candidates that you
know that I that I favored and
contribute my my services but I didn't
have a company and I never even imagined
that I would do this other than as I as
for fun as a volunteer ISM but you know
it was his campaign in 1980 and he
decided whatever reason not to use the
pollster he was using and decided to use
me and so the first major campaign I did
and was with senator Dodds campaign in
19 1980 and I'm sure I learned it all
there what were you doing well I was
teach I was teach I was teaching at Yale
as I was in New Haven so I was in
Connecticut I was my wife was working on
that campaign the I was involved in a
targeting group that was doing
statistical analysis of you know of a
precinct level data he asked me to do
kind of take a second look at the
polling data he was getting from his
pollster and decided based on the second
look that maybe
to do the first look and so I did his
campaign which really was really the
first campaign that I've ever done at
least chair of the Democratic Party and
I'm happy to be in his wake
your wife is congresswoman rosa DeLauro
how long have you been married we've
been married for 16 years Jimmy I'm in a
campaign I was this quirky professor
that got asked to help out in a in a 75
mayoral election in New Haven and and we
began to in 76 we began to work on some
campaigns together and then it hit
blossom we blew both a and trophy pizza
and we both had our coffee with cream
and sugar and and if you've been through
campaigns when they were argue when you
go get the fast food stuff and bring it
bring it into the campaign headquarters
people who drink the same things and eat
the same things gravitate to each other
and she's in what term she's in her
third term just liked it or third term
in Congress it doesn't have any impact
on either one of you that you're both
fairly high-profile in this town right
now well for a long time people didn't
know we're married it was actually it
was it was intriguing the the she worked
for Senator Dodd as she was senator Dodd
is chief of staff for six years
and then was in headed up the campaign
den contra 8 and eventually ran for
Congress herself I mean I was a Yale I
was not you know in this town I taught
at Yale until 87 so there's an
impression because I worked for the
president that I've been in Washington
working for a very long time it's
actually not not the case so the and I
said come down and do polling from time
to time but I was still based at Yale
and in New Haven so it's only in recent
years we find ourselves together it's
generally known though is sometimes the
papers get it wrong but most people now
know that we're we're married one of the
things that you learn in your book is
that you do a lot of focus groups a a
lot of polling but focus groups where
you sit around and listen to folks tell
you what they think how does that work
how do you put together a focus group
how do you select new people well you
know my entree into the reason I can't
made
transition from being an academia to
being to being a pollster is is largely
I think because of focus groups my I as
an academic I've done books on a number
of subjects they haven't been bought by
many people no read for many people the
but they almost always are based on
one-on-one interviews in-depth
interviews with people and so I've I've
always tried to kind of construct a
sense of reality from the way people
understand it and try to develop
patterns out of people's thinking that's
true of my work on politics of poverty
I've also done work on comparative race
relations in a tea in 1984 the Democrats
got slaughtered nationally and in
particularly in Michigan and which was a
you know strong Democratic state union
state in 1985 in Macomb County which was
a suburban area of Michigan heart of the
UAW 40 percent UAW members Ronald Reagan
got 67% of the vote it was shattering
Democrats would held every position lost
half the legislative positions and so I
was asked to come out in part because I
had started to do this political polling
but also because of the kind of
one-on-one in-depth interviewing that I
do that they thought maybe we could get
at get at a deeper understanding what
was going on so I organized focus groups
the Democrats for the most part had not
done a lot of these before Republicans I
think had but Democrats had not focus
troops there's really small group
discussions to you know ten or twelve
people in a room of talk for for a
couple hours and try to get at get wait
you know get beyond the kind of
structured questions you get in a normal
survey and have a more in-depth
conversation the key is is homogeneity
the key is to have people who are
like-minded similar and background who
are comfortable enough with each other
that they can say what's on their mind
they don't feel inhibited by the the
nature of the group and so the groups we
did in 1985 were you know we were all
white groups in you know suburban Macomb
County one group was all Union members
these were all democratic defectors
these were all people who had voted
Democratic in the past and and who voted
for Ronald Reagan how do you find them
well you do pretty interviews I mean you
do you actually can
to survey you ask questions you see
whether people qualify then you ask them
whether they'll participate in the focus
group usually pay them to come
participate thirty five dollars I forget
what it was then thirty five fifty
dollars to come participate when then
now you do these things are done in
focus group facilities they're actually
a conference type room there's a one-way
mirror you can observe you know the
discussions going on then they know by
the way there's one way we actually tell
them we you know there's a you know
usually there's a microphone there and
you point it out you know so you want to
create a comfortable context people
aren't being deceived
they're told that they're people behind
the glass or observing but in when we
when I started this n85 there weren't
very many of such facilities we did some
of these in bars and back rooms of bars
some of them in hotels and so it was a
it was money was it was much less formal
you reclaimed them we record them and
transcribed them and so that I mean I
will you know I'll listen to the
conversation myself I like to be there
like to see the body language and I'll
then usually read through the
transcripts at least twice do you do I
or something I know he's a moderator
though you somebody has you know has
trained with the skills to facilitate
you know conversation and so the what
happened in the in those groups then
part of which is in the chapter on
Macomb County is we raised the race
issue and unbelievable emotion came
pouring out we read I've been reading a
statement attributed to Robert Kennedy
about the obligations to address this is
a civil rights issue and the you know
people started saying things like no
wonder they shot him it was a it was it
was a very strong response to and became
very clear and people were quite willing
in this setting to talk in in great
depth about the the sense of grievance
on race grounds and how that was coming
to shape their whole view of the
Democratic Party and of the role of
government and that if I mean at the
time I advise that if Democrats didn't
come to terms with us they working you
know they were gonna lose middle America
you you keep their names confidential
yes and so no one will ever know
who said what that's right okay let me
read you some of the words that you took
out of a focus group from one you did on
Ross Perot I believe would you do one
just on Ross Perot we we did a good
study for the which is part of this on
where we talk to people who have just
voted for us program and I the reason I
want to do this is looking to the next
election in 1996 the Perot voters and
where they're gonna go is that of
concern to you sure it is how about
these words spending crooks they don't
live in the real world greed rich men
jerks insensitive jerks spending money I
think of them as a big block wall
stopping everything from happening
thieves waste bad checks special
interest you only hear those kinds of
things from Perot voters you get it
beyond bro voters uh the this was done
in a focus group where we just said what
comes to mind when you hear the word
Congress and this trend since this came
out and it's it's also it's very
important because the you get a sense of
it's not just the words you know
sometimes you say you know what comes
them you know it to mine when you know
when you hear Betty Crocker or something
in people will you know sit back and try
to think when you say Congress its
immediate so I guess you know it's like
a machine gun
just boom boom boom boom it's like top
of mind people have very strong feelings
and what what I you know what I argue
here is that the Congress has become a
symbol of a corrupted politics where
ordinary people have their interest
their values have been had left out
ignored that the people who go to
Washington get caught up in the special
interest politics become arrogant become
out of touch and the Congress symbolizes
our politics is that it's not literally
about Congress they are the way are
seemed to be kind of the worst form of
what happens to politics in our in our
era Ross Perot I believe was the
antidote to Congress that that was
everything they disliked about Congress
they liked about Ross Perot that is he
was for that people didn't forget didn't
forget those people gets things done not
caught in gridlock not arrogant you know
can do so now it wasn't an idea the
parameters were not very ideological but
I think their consciousness was shaped
by their by their perceptions of
Congress and I
think they read into Ross Perot the
things that they hated about politics 96
if there are only two candidates where
were those Ross Perot voters go based on
your experience in 1992 the the all the
survey showed that had Perot voters had
to vote in a two way contest they would
have split evenly between Bush and
Clinton now since they were the
Overton's Perot voters are
overwhelmingly Republican in their
voting history
I mean Perot voters are you know
libertarian more secular disaffected
Republicans who've pulled out of that
coalition but they would have split
evenly between Clinton and Bush that
meant that Clinton probably would have
gotten about 53 54 percent of the vote
in a two way race in the congressional
elections 94 they went to the one for
Republicans in 94 that obviously would
be a very serious problem if that were
to be maintained 296 but I'm confident
that we're going to be dealing with a
different mood come 96 Perot voters are
strongly populist and anti-establishment
similar in their thinking to Democratic
presidential voters that's what you
wrote what do you mean by that well it's
interesting it's very it's very very
easy to miss read the borough voters
they and and to read into Perot voters
what you what you want to what you want
to believe the Republicans tend to see
because Perot voters are focused on the
deficit is one of the things they care
about Republicans think that Perot
voters are anti-government our
conservative philosophically but they
actually parallel Perot himself who I
mean Perot was very focused on the
deficit but at the same time that he was
for cutting government spending in the
deficit he was also for strong
industrial policy from massive
infrastructure projects talked about the
space program the highway program as
models for you know for governmental
policy they actually want accountable
governments was a small-scale government
that works for people they are they are
very populous which is a point to which
is relates to the point you're raising
but they are they but they are they are
they are populist both in political
terms and economic terms that is they
resent political power and there is an
economic power and in some ways they're
even more populous than than the than
the Democratic voters how
how white are they they're very white
any any any other well I'm sure I mean
the Pro voters are I mean the group that
really I mean there's lots of different
kinds of Pro voters and for example the
under third do a lot of under 30 Perot
voters who are there because these are
very independent voters who've never
belonged to a party and Perot is an easy
outlet and there's not a lot of
philosophical identification with Perot
it's the independence that they like but
when you get beyond the under 30 the the
biggest block are non-college younger
men and below 50 none people without a
college degree men this is is the next
biggest block of Perot voters they're a
very alienated block that is they they
are politically alienated they think the
political system doesn't care about them
at the same time this is a group whose
incomes have declined in real terms more
than almost any other group in the
electorate and they're so they resent
what you know they resent what's
happening with the economy they resent
the official statistics to say things
are getting better and so they are so
they are you know they're populist
instincts carry over to both the
political and economic room you say they
held Ronald Reagan in low esteem ya know
the bro vote which is very interesting
given given the Republican history the
promoters it is support now I'm talking
about at the time of the 1992 election
you know the you know as you get further
away from the Reagan presidency and
you're dealing with a retiring Ronald
Reagan with you know who people are
following his current difficulties I'm
sure if we asked about Ronald Reagan we
get a different result right now but
it's when we asked about this is after
the 92 election in 93 when you asked
about Ronald Reagan Perot voters gave
him quite negative scores
I mean parole voters do believe the
Republicans exploded the deficit that
they tore to fate you know too favorable
to the wealthy
these are populist voters now they're
also anti-government I mean what what
Republicans don't understand and perhaps
if Democrats don't understand these
people are both anti-government and anti
economic power
there are anti concentrations of power
they're fertile Erfurt you know they're
there for the common person you say that
anti-establishment anti-government
sentiment leaves them estranged from all
the power centers and society is there
ever a point that they would be drawn
into the parson
is there any way that they would like
what the power centers do well I mean
they would I don't feel like it the
event went like they were rebels in 92
against the Republicans they were rebels
in 94 against the Democrats I don't know
what they're gonna be in 96 I truly I
truly don't know how many of them are
there well no there's a good 20% of the
electorate that you know are committed
to being independent voters anti-party
and three-quarters of them were perot
voters so that there's a big block of
potential Perot voters or potential
voters or an independent candidacy of
some kind what do you say Stan Greenberg
you're sitting in front of the President
of the United States Bill Clinton and
the word just comes in Ross Perot is
running for president 1995-1996 what's
your reaction you know it's interesting
I remember at the time of the Democrat
convention I was there with with the
presidential candidate Bill Clinton when
he withdrew and I remember everybody
immediately jumped to you know
conclusions whether this is good or bad
you know bad for us everybody had their
own and his for his first instinct was
to say that this you know that this he
did it for personal reasons that and we
need to know we should understand his
personal reasons there's a lot of
humanity in the president that was he
refused he declined political
calculation you know he was identifying
with somebody facing a very tough choice
and decided not to run been suspected
with personal reasons for it then I
guess I'm not sure how the president
would respond in that particular
circumstance my own my own position is
gonna you're gonna see as a fudge the
when they're in 92 when there was the
prospect of a of a parole candidacy you
know some people began to say well you
know Democrats they they need a 43%
strategy not a 51% strategy they in a
3-way race they should go for 43% that
means you know solidifying your base go
after the union vote get them an already
vote after the urban vote and you can
it'll add up to you know to 43% I was
always in the view that that if you're
gonna if you aim for 43% you're gonna
get 37% and you're gonna loses and and
more important than that parties have
obligations it's part of I think the the
message of this book for our Tea Parties
have obligations this is a compact
between the vision and the promises that
a party offers and Pete and the
citizenry's hope for their own
there's a compact there that's real it
needs to be bigger the Democrats had to
reach to be a majority party even if
there was a fractured vote it was it's
both right and it's also the best it's a
you know tactic but it's also right in a
larger sense and I I think the same
thing is true here I don't I don't know
whether we're better off in a two-way or
a three-way race I can imagine scenarios
for winning two-way races or winning
through a races what is your opinion
about the 20 percent and Ross Perot
mm-hmm in this day and age will they go
will they support him I think the Ross
Perot would be viable if you you know
runs I mean now I'm not viable in the
sense of you know winning the election I
think there are limits on his ability to
grow beyond him beyond the base he had
but you know but Ron's me Russborough
represents something and if he runs
he'll have significant support your
first candidate is the chairman of the
Democratic National Committee your wife
is a congresswoman from Connecticut and
keep deputy with chief deputy whip and
your your your chief quiet is in the
Oval Office does it get any better than
this and you got a better
well working for Nelson Mandela was I
was it was it was okay and what you do
for him we did the poll we did the
polling for his his presidential
campaign how well did you get to know
pretty well ultimately worked in a you
know with a fairly a reasonably small
group of people that was the central
advisory group for the campaign they
formed a command center or something
like with the war room formed in the in
the Clinton campaign which I was part of
where did he get the idea to hire you
see I you know I haven't we haven't gone
through my whole biography yet I have a
you know an academic history which
ultimately lapped over to doing work in
South Africa I did work on I went from
my work I should have actually answered
this on your question about history when
I'm after I finished a book on on
politics and poverty and doing the
history of migration I began to do a
work a book on comparative race
relations to try to understand better
understand American race relations and
ended up going to the deep south but
also South Africa spent a lot of time in
South Africa as a part of writing
writing that book became
director associate director of the
southern african research program of
yale and so i had a so i have a
long-standing southern african interest
which has taken me back year after year
so that with the first democratic
elections in South Africa having the
experience here electoral a band but
also the exhibit the experience on the
ground in South Africa it was I think a
reasonable reach to try to have me get
involved what did you see in Nelson
Mandela up close if we don't see on time
he's tremendously gracious actually
extraordinarily gracious if you I mean
he's I mean he's a historic figure that
and which is which he carries with him
at the same time if you sit down he'll
go get your drink lots of water or your
coffee or I mean he will go to great
lengths to make sure you're comfortable
when to the care for you ease of areas
as a very tender gracious person it's an
extraordinary combination
he was also he's very tough-minded I
don't know whether that you know comes
through publicly it's obviously members
of his own acts acts of rebellion that I
have being in jail for 27 years in a
spirit coming out but I've seen him turn
to his political associates and those in
the campaign and say I understand all
the political reasons I understand all
the people will be offended we're not
doing it and yeah they have a big sense
of history and he knew where he had to
take the the party so he has he's tough
minded where were you born I was born in
Philadelphia until I was was there until
I was five and came with my parents to
Washington I've had nothing to do with
government or politics my father was an
it was an engineer worked in a company
in Silver Spring Maryland but I grew up
went through the public schools in
Washington was lived through the
desegregation of the public schools I
lived in an all-black neighborhood when
I for at least the first three years
that I was in the district but I went I
went to an all-white school that I just
climbed over the fence and but all my
all my friend
and neighbors they all had to travel to
to a more distance to school and then
and that ended up being after was
integrated ended after we moved to a -
Briggs Park which is a lower
middle-class Jewish neighborhood ended
up being bused to a back into a black
school with one of about I think 30 kids
white kids in the in that in that school
eventually ended up at the Montgomery
Blair high school in Silver Spring went
to Miami University Ohio then to Harvard
for a PhD what year did you get out of
Miami 67 you were at Yale at any time
when the president was there well I I
went and said I went in 70 and so I you
know I looked at the teacher
first course she taught first first
course that the courses I thought were
on urban politics when did you first
meet Bill Clinton I met him on some
conference of panels on on education
some years ago I can't remember when but
the first real serious contact was the
1990 gubernatorial election where I came
in after the primary to help think
through how to develop the themes for
his general election campaign
what was his status he had a tough
primer I mean he's been he's been in
office he'd been in office now you know
almost a decade and as you know as mario
cuomo knows it's hard after after being
in office that long could make the case
that you still have an unfinished agenda
that you have you know new things to do
he had just he had had a fairly rough
primary but then it was a lot concerned
about the general election so they
wanted to get it right and so there were
a number of us who helped out what was
the reason he called on you I think
largely cause of focus-group skills
because of you know the the work I do is
very you know it's very thematic it's
trying to understand you know underlying
feelings and get beyond the surface
impressions
I think wanted to have a deeper sense of
the way people understood his his
leadership and understand the kind of
case he would make for his reelection
and then what did you do in the 1990
campaign that had an impact that he held
on to you and here's June 92 you never
know how these things feed in I think
what I'm impressed with I did the idea
of these focus groups was in various
parts of Arkansas and I even he wondered
some immediate reading on this thing and
he's a night person so he wanted to do
this after the after the groups are over
I'm a morning person I have you know
great trouble with moving my lips at
night to speak and I began to try to
present I really couldn't do it and and
also needed more time so they agreed to
come back in the morning we do this
thing at 7:30 in the morning and so I
stayed up and worked on this thing and
he's not a morning person he doesn't
like to get a brew and do these things
but he was there at 7:30 I overslept
missed the meeting but despite all that
we ended up working together
middle-class dreams the title of your
book what is the middle class well it's
more an idea it's a more normative
concept than it is just a material
concept the easiest way to define it is
in income terms and so it probably
includes people earning up to $50,000
60,000
you're in and I would include 50 to 60%
of the of the country but I but I don't
think of it in in those kind of material
terms I don't I don't think most of the
people think about middle class in the
country think about it they think of it
more as the people who do the right
things in life who you know support
their family go to work every day get a
wage or salary and try to and try to
make sure their kids have a better life
so it's much more a set of values and a
way in a way of life which most people
in this country the overwhelming portion
of people in this country identify with
they either believe they're middle class
or believe that should be middle class
or believe their their their family
their kids should be middle clients and
they an above all believe that the
values of middle-class life ought to be
honored oughta come first oughta have
primacy ought to be honored and they
think and they think those values have
been neglect
ignored trampled on and they what people
were hoping for is a restoration of
respect for those values I called the
book middle-class Dreams not not a
middle-class revolt in part because I
don't think these people want to be
rebels they don't want to spend their
lives in rebellion against politics
they're looking for something more
fundamental they're looking for a sense
that our political life will honor their
values and make it possible for them to
have stronger families and rising living
standards what percentage of the voters
consider themselves middle-class well if
you ask it just straight out our you
know what class are you middle class a
working class middle class upper class
45% say working class 45% no say middle
class if you say lower middle class and
upper class it's about 75% we'll say
middle classes if you cast in those
terms so a lot of it depends on on the
on the terminology you use but even many
of those people who say they're working
class you know will you know will say
yeah I used to be middle class and then
before I got you know squeezed and we
worked so hard my wife went to work and
now we don't have enough money you know
to our income is are declining we don't
have money to send our kids to school
and so I've been pushed down so there
there's a sense of decline a sense that
the middle class is shrinking there's a
very strong sense in the country of the
middle class is shrinking I presented a
chart actually to to middle class voters
that is precisely the chart where I ask
people to react to the chart and what it
shows you know if you look at it more
closely when you read when you read the
book that that you know the middle class
isn't shrinking the middle class is
there is a great bulge in the middle
which remained fairly stagnant over the
last couple decades that but it violates
voters visible their sense there of
what's happening the middle class what
they think is being it's been shrinking
the lower class to be is rising in the
upper classes rising in the middle
classes is squeezed in the middle so the
statistical sense of the middle class is
somewhat at odds with people's visible
sense of the middle class well this is
hard to describe I mean people are
looking at this chart we were showing it
that but what this shows that that on
the far right if you're looking at it on
the screen people are much closer
together and income and they were
in the early days back over here you see
there was an in the fifties you'll see
that the the the percentage of people
who were working class lower classes
dominates the income spectrum 1992 how
much work did you do for the president
the I mean is actually it's I only did
one other race other than the president
I was Krista heads raised for the
reelection race for the for the for the
Senate no I we know I devoted myself
wholly entirely completely to the
election of Bill Clinton is president
knighted States
when did you start on September 9th 91
he announced in the first weekend rocked
of October I participated in discussions
leading up to you know whether he was
gonna run in September the real work
began who was in the group Bruce Lindsay
was was there Frank Greer was there
myself the first lady
Gloria cabe who's Gloria cave Clerk aid
was his chief of staff and as a in the
governor's office there had a very long
political history with him tell me
somebody whose judgment he trusted and
so it was a fairly you know fairly small
small group of people now when you say
that and one of the unique things about
the president is is these networks of
associations he has from his life you
know the aqua he has a network of people
from Oxford that he went through the
Rhodes experience with that he's carried
with him but were some of his closest
friends some of whom are now in the
administration from Secretary Rice
strobe Talbot but he also has his
governor he also has his governor's
Network he was head of the Governors
Association in his close associations
with former governors and so by time in
a fairly short period of time say in
September before it even finally firmly
made the decision to run we had some
fairly large meetings and
in Washington were many of these people
from the various parts of his life came
together to to help talk through the
idea of running for the Presidency
announcer 1 October you have 91 between
September of 91 and the end of the
campaign if we'd have followed you
around on a day-to-day basis what would
we have seen you doing the most I've
probably been on conference calls
endless conference calls to that this
was a campaign that was had an Arkansas
piece had a you know had a Washington DC
piece and then had a piece in the
various primary states and so much of
for a long period of time that much of
the communication was it was done
you know bike by conference call there
wasn't a lot of research done at the at
the outset he had he had been head of
the Democratic Leadership Council for
almost a year when he ran for president
and speaking around the country had
given you know quite I think seminal
speeches his Cleveland speech for the
DLC there was I think a seminal speech
when they were before there was any
campaign so he knew he knew what I did
he knew the the ideas that he was gonna
run on for president before there was
any group of advisers sitting there
saying this is what you ought to do and
so he did isn't his announcement speech
which in October there was never any
research you know to get you know test
that speech or anything it was just it
was based on the ideas he had developed
over the years but you know what's one
of the interesting things I think that I
discovered in the book if you asked me
what the biggest surprise was for me in
the book was the president 74
Congressional Campaign which I had it
just wasn't in my consciousness when I
started to do this book and the books
not about the president the book is much
more about you know the forces around
the Clinton presidency shaping our
politics and there's a chapter that I
could go back and look at the ideas that
the president has put on the table but
if you go back to 1974 he when he firt
when the president first ran for office
first race for Congress which he lost
Arkansas was the second poorest state
and he ran for Congress in the northwest
corner of the state which was the
poorest part of Arkansas included the
Ozark so these were the poorest white
people in America
they had many of mid voted for George
Wallace this was a very tough place for
a young guy out of law school who worked
as work for George McGovern
not to run for Congress he was running
against a an incumbent who had been
elected repeatedly with you know 70
around 70 percent of the vote John Paul
hammerschmidt right and Bill Clinton got
about 49% of the vote in the end it was
a extraordinarily close race but when
you look at it you see a person talking
about first populist issues that we
shouldn't have being allow all companies
to reap windfall profits those profits
should be taxed away he was talking
about education and investment that he
he wanted a major federal role in
investing in education particularly for
poor states like Arkansas which couldn't
afford the raise up the skill levels of
its own people but educate but
investment of people was the the second
plank and then the third plank was the
arrogant government in Washington the
outer pound and they out of balanced
budgets and the big bureaucracy which
had to be cut back so in 1974 he was
running for Congress before I presume he
knew any pollsters or consultants or any
of these people in Washington he was
running on themes of you know
accountable government investment in
people and giving the power to the
average person he was running on those
themes in 1774 there's a consistency of
viewpoint over two decades which is
actually quite quite extraordinary and
those are important ideas now when we
think about how our politics get
reformed one of the things and you go
back to that by the way you say he was
jumped in the Chevelle truck with
astroturf in the back back in 1974 right
picked over around the district joven a
what was it a gremlin and 1970 another
car that we don't switch in the gremlin
you switch to the girl switch to the
grandma go back to this business about
talking about the the big moneyed
interest of the big lobbies or the
special interests and all that has he
dealt with that yet in this presidency I
mean we keep reading about that one
segment the money in politics hasn't
been dealt with either by the Congress
or the presidency and going to meet the
Perot voters go back to your parole
voters they keep bringing that up
is he gonna deal with that between now
and the time he runs yeah I can't speak
for what he's gonna deal with I mean I
do but I do believe it is one of the big
unresolved questions
in our politics which is that the
special interests which plays such a big
role in Washington are still playing
such a big role
I watched the Republicans when they
after that when they were celebrating
the the scaling back of environmental
regulation flanked by representatives of
big business saying isn't this great
what we've done I think they miss read
the Perot voters no I think they miss
read this period in time if you think
what people want is the turnover power
simply turn over power to business I
think that I think the public has a
skeptical of power both economic and
political power and the I think the test
that the public brings to their members
of Congress and this and to some extent
their leaders and George Bush failed by
that test the test they bring is are
they representing me you know are they
going there and becoming part of the
establishment and you know and doing
politics as usual or do they Road do
they represent me folks like me I think
it's very much unresolved for people I
think the president's taking on some you
know I think he's seen actually more
than any previous president someone in
touch with average people and that's I
think the if the fact that he's I
believe still in in the game for 1996
given the problems of 94 is is a
testimony to the fact that he has seemed
to be a president who's in touch with
ordinary people but in this town you
still have you know you still have
issues of campaign finance reform
political reform that have not not been
addressed and I think they need to be
addressed as you know it's part of a
broader initiative to establish that the
Democratic Party and the president are
rooted in the people in the end in the
end you got to come back to these two
party traditions I and it's very
tempting to say and sometimes I think
this you know that look you have these
two party traditions a bottom-up
tradition and a top-down their outdated
and let's let's go to something else
the problem is what else so I mean the
the problem what when you move away from
those party traditions what you end up
with is a highly personalized kind of
politics around you know such as we got
around the Perot candidacy I think the
Democratic and Republican Party still
have to figure out
to renew themself in this era and
Democrats ultimately still have to come
back to the question how do you
represent the common person in this new
economic era that I think is the
challenge that faces the Democrats have
you ever said to the president you've
got to be here by middle of 1996 now
you've got out of work through all these
things I'm hearing when was the last
time you were in Macomb County Michigan
for the focus groups Ralph the election
and where is that physically it's just
north of the suburbs just north of the
city of Detroit you got if you get to
the Metropolitan Airport there and you
drive it how long is it take you to get
there there's about 45 minutes from the
airport and when you go there to do your
focus groups where do you do in the mall
in a mall right the malls are now the
the cultural center of the suburban
America and therefore the center of
America where do you sit well these are
this is an office this is an office a
research facility that are located in
the mall people go to the mall and then
they go to this office where there's a
conference room will you go back there
soon to check again or I'm not going I'm
going to Macomb County as part of the
book tour for this there'll be a a
library a library launch with the
Detroit Free Press for the book well I
really meant will you go back there soon
to do another focus group at some point
I'm sure I'll go back from from time to
time I still I still consider it the a
the best the best place to read where
America is going and if you go back
there what kind of things will you look
for what kind of groups do you want to
assemble if you let's say after this
discussion here we decide we want to go
back to Macomb we want to get a group
together who are the groups you want to
hear from right now well I mean it's you
should it's still the case that there
that the there is an independent bloc
that's disconnected from the parties you
know middle range of income that you
know can easily vote Democratic for
Congress I mean David bonheur who's the
the whip the Minority Whip you know got
almost 65 percent of the vote in it
largely Macomb County district and at
the same time they voted heavily for
John Engler Republican for governor and
those those are the swing voters that
that
we ought to be talking to we need to
understand why you know what what takes
them between a tax-cutting John
government cutting John Engler and a
populist gritty guy like David Bonney
with roots in the community how what
what takes them between those two kinds
of of officeholders and you know how do
they understand the challenges facing
their community and families now since
the president has been in office have
you done focus groups on his behalf I we
have a research program with the
Democratic National Committee on behalf
of the White House and another
Democratic candidate so indeed how does
he find out do you go in and sit with
him and tell him well it's you know it
varies by what's going on in any given
time I mean they're bent up different
periods of times where I've you know sat
with the president it there's a long
tradition I mean people pollsters and
there's a long tradition with presidents
of having pollsters who advise them the
Franklin Roosevelt got polling
information on on bombing sites in
Europe whether you would hit religious
sites or not you had under Eisenhower
the State Department ran a a major
polling program on on where you draw our
misses lines in North Korea whether you
get involved in Indochina right through
his you know through his presidency
Paris was the pollster for John Kennedy
he says he used to talk to him on the
phone about three times a week about
various issues Richard Nixon had polling
on the incursions into Cambodia and the
bombing of North Vietnam and the China
opening to China Ronald Reagan had
polling on a leadership style on how to
best develop the leadership style he had
polling on his negotiating position with
the Soviet Union on how to best
communicate you know the both strength
and openness and and so it it there's a
long tradition of there being you know
polling research available to presidents
in various forms of how its presented
really depends on what you know what's
going on at the White House at a given
time but does it work for you to go out
and listen to what the public wants tell
the president then have him go out and
tell the public know what they want to
hear no I mean you know it's not that
literal and it and do it to be honest
what what are the one the striking
things I
about the the president is that we've
never pulled his agenda we've never had
to say well what should you be for that
you know the as I said with his
announcement speech he developed his
ideas alive he was running for president
independently indeed of you see in the
book he probably developed these ideas
two decades ago we'd like to think we're
all very important to what he says but I
think his own consciousness is his own
beliefs or what or what mainly drives it
but we've never had the poll on whether
we should be for you know for how should
he do a health care initiative should he
do it at a deficit reduction plan we've
never had the poll on you know should he
do that his agenda you know was set in
the campaign was set in the transition
and even on health care where we did a
fair amount of research and I've never
pulled until after the plan itself was
developed so there was no you know it
was except for minor issues there was no
polling on you know should we do a
single-payer system or should it be a
mixed system or should it be a minimal
you know private sectors for a system we
never pulled on the type of health care
proposal you know what we did research
on is once you know once once you know
this is an issue of your taking and this
is the form of it you know how do you
make the best case what's your what's
your best case on this where what are
the water people's biggest doubts what
are the questions you need to answer
when you're gonna make your case for
this initiative you uh you have some
space in here devoted to Vietnam and and
I underlined a bunch of stutters his
belief that the government could be
trusted to do what is right drop 22
points between 1964 and 70 belief that
the government has run for the benefit
of the people not for the one few big
interest dropped 26 points between 64
and 72 and then you go on to reflect
what people said about the Vietnam War
and the deceit that people felt in this
particular group what impact from what
you know of history did the Vietnam War
have about the attitudes that people
have in this country today profound as
reflected in that and that data though
there are two sets of events going on in
the 1960s and it's hard to untangle the
one set of events was the civil rights
movement the urban riots the
school busing initiatives and the anti
busing campaigns which took place in 70s
or 60s and early 70s
then you also had the Vietnam War which
which heated up in the mid mid 60s and
where a majority the public turned
against it before the end of the 60s of
both both of those formative events are
taking place at the same time I I
believe that the civil that the that the
racial issues were were more striking
that they began the decline in
confidence in government and belief that
people represented them happen before
the majority formed against the Vietnam
War which suggests that the racial
issues are at least predate the Vietnam
thing but I'm not sure we have to
untangle both of them were very quite
powerful and had an enormous impact
but-but-but part of the significance for
this story that I'm telling in the book
I talk about these two great partiers
the Democrat the Republican here and the
Democratic era Democratic hero was from
32 to - it's a 62 and there exist before
the Republican arrow is from 1896 to at
the 1928 the but there were two attempts
to renew to renew these visions the too
bold attempts that renew it one was
Lyndon Johnson's Great Society Democrats
were actually Lu almost losing their
hold they were very competitive
elections John Kennedy barely was
elected even though the country was just
had gone through a recession so the the
country was very evenly divided
electoral it by 1960
Lyndon Johnson's Great Society was and
it was a attempt it may be forced by
history may be created by Lyndon
Johnson's own sense of moment in
responding to the civil rights crisis in
the country but it produced a racial
polarization of the of the electorate it
racial racial realignment of the parties
a very profound impact on the parties
and it was associated with a major
collapse of confidence and put in
political leaders in the country which
came through to the Tivat to the Nixon
presidency so in the middle 60s to the
to the early 70s you saw this
extraordinary drop in confidence in
political institutions and political
leaders but then was pretty steady and
it was pretty steady up until 1988
and the next big drop that you get in
confidence and political leaders and
institutions was under the George Bush
presidency from 88 to 92 it was a we
should not underestimate many many
Republicans look at the George Bush
presidency and saying well it's just a
it's a blip you know he you know he
promised read my lips didn't do it he
wasn't true enough to Reagan let's go
back but there was something much much
bigger going on in the Bush presidency
which had to one there was the betrayal
on taxes but also it was two other
things were going on people were also
critical of Reaganism it wasn't just
George Bush that people were upset with
and people were have developing a much
bigger view of the economy being in
trouble this is not just recession
people were coming to believe that
incomes were stagnant for the long term
and the political institutions were
trapped in in passing gridlock under
Bush and the Democratic Congress and so
the public turned again turned away from
that it turned away from political
leaders and institutions in that period
on almost the same level that they
turned away from it in the period of the
1960s we quote from some of the exempt
okis groups by the way to do the focus
groups I'm getting on yourself uh yes I
have a moderator who you know doesn't
buy observe the groups it said aside
from my friends being killed was that it
finally hit me how rotten our government
really can be my own personal anger what
does it come from it comes from being
deceived
I think the Vietnam War did more to
destroy American people's faith in
government than anything else no
question they just lied to us
how much of that is left and how much of
that transfers over to the parol voter
well yeah when you we forget sometimes
when John Kennedy assumed office seventy
five percent of Americans said that most
public officials will do the right thing
most of the time seventy-five percent
John Kennedy's the negative job
performance for John Kennedy as
president did not reach double digits
disapproval of the President did not
reach double-digit for two years right
now only about 18 percent think that the
the political leaders do the right thing
most of the time used to be 75 percent
it's now 18 percent Bill Clinton's job
disapproval people saying he's doing a
bad job in office was 26 percent the day
took office the date of office
we're living with the legacy I think of
Vietnam no the upheavals of the none of
the 1960s including the race issue of
the political impasse and the
insensitivity to average people under
under George Bush and that's the context
in which we have gone through the 92
election and I think the 94 election
both of which I believe are an
inheritance of those of those changes
man has produced a very very volatile
political situation in America where do
you live now I live in New Haven
Connecticut give children I have three
children who were grown to their 26 one
is working on her dissertation in
political science at university cago and
she was one of the critics on the book
along with my brother is a political
scientist I have a daughter who was
assistant director of a program called
hippy USA it's a preschool program for
home instruction for parents teaching
their kids it's spreading and growing
across the country and she's getting and
finishing her master's and I have a son
who's here living with us and his art
place here in DC who's working for the
National Wildlife Federation are you
gonna work on the 96 campaign for the
presidents my expectation and I look
forward to a big reelected
I'll boy I'll wake the write the next
book until after he finishes a second
term define your own politics in this
stage in your life and by the way how
old are you know 49 I don't know right
now frankly it's hard to disassociate my
politics from the from the from the
president's politics I mean I I think he
he helped create a moment in history
he's also I think President during a
formative period in our history and
whether he succeeds or not is just
fundamental to what kind of politics we
have as a country and whether we and
whether we have an optimistic politics
or whether we fall deeper into the
cynicism and he's an instinctively
optimistic person so the project of
a Bill Clinton success as president and
a successful presidency is so central to
you know everything I care about well
that I that I associated my politics
with his presidency worried you haven't
know where this idea came from here and
what is it well it's the publishers idea
but I think got it from a tag sale which
includes Allen broader here of the
American flag and I'm
sure to suggest the an imagery that
suggests middle-class way of life which
i think is at stake in which is leading
middle-class America who want to see our
politics at work to help preserve you
mentioned that you grew up in a black
neighborhood here in Washington what
impact did that have on your never
figure I've never figured out if I when
I try to reflect on why I do what I do
because my parents weren't particularly
political and so and they ended up with
two sons that are political scientists
and the the I mean in my first politics
that was civil rights politics and I
worked when I left high school before I
went to college I I worked in a factory
making minimum wage down to quarter an
hour in Laurel and Laurel Maryland was
always a the factory which was
segregated the the most of the white
workers had come coming from Appalachia
so I was a very strong there were strong
racist currents and if the black workers
were only in the thin thing in the
shipping department but it was 63 it was
the summer of the march on Washington so
I would work there during the day that
night I went down and worked at the
n-double-a-cp offices with Reverend Phan
Troy on the march on Washington so
somehow out of all this I'm sure there's
a their beliefs that have shaped what
I'm now doing it was the first civil
rights as you know I noticed you
mentioned you've been to Birmingham was
that and in conjuction
there was no I was part of him when I
did the the book politics in poverty and
then when I did the book race and state
one of the one of the one of the areas
that I studied was the was was Alabama
and I studied developing of race
relations and an industrial growth in
Alabama and so I spent a fair amount of
time in Birmingham talking to people
understanding the history here's what
the book looks like our guest has been
the author Stanley greenberg and the
title is middle-class Dreams thank you
for joining us